[Musique]
mais le cachet si l'olympique 2
l'objectif premier du club avait la
ferme c'est essayer de sauver le dernièr
élevage d'une commune rurale voilà et
c'est ça qui est important parce qu'en
fait on fait pas du cabaret pour faire
du cabaret ont fait du cabaret ont fait
la boutique des producteurs pour sauver
le dernier élevage de la commune
[Musique]
on est devenu le premier cabaret à la
ferme de france dans lequel chacun a une
mission bien précise à l'agriculteur
doit présenter des spectacles dans
l'assiette les artistes présentent le
spectacle sur scène et ensemble et des
deux spectacles le consommateur permet
donc justement à la possibilité d'avoir
le spectacle gustatives et visuel on et
merveilles à la fois les papilles et les
pupilles
[Musique]
80% des produits concerts pendant le
repas qui viennent à moins de 50 km de
la ferme c'est pour ça que nous on se
permet de parler de spectacle dans
l'assiette un repas aux produits du
terroir un plus servi par les
producteurs en personne
[Musique]